it is time for drew's news your daily
skip down the good news lane and with me
at the desk is the best co-pilot in the
biz rossy ross
so
matthews
um about the stories we get to tell
every day i love researching them i love
reading them i love
unveiling them it's news you can use it
is but can i just give it an award first
for best skirt of the day drew barrymore
your skirt is so cute
well i'm right feeling uh
you in the front row we clearly went for
an ombre effect today yes it's an ombre
kind of day and i approve you look good
well you've got the first story all
right you ready for some stories i got a
good one for you
first up always always you know it's
always a joy to see the people we love
totally fan out about other things like
when you see a celebrity loving other
celebrities and movies well i love this
variety reports lady gaga just got to
reveal to jake gyllenhaal that she's
obsessed with his movie donnie darko um
and that's of course the 2001 indie hit
that turned into a gigantic cult classic
uh by the way it was produced by none
other than drew barrymore in flower
films
and it inspired lady gaga she said when
she was a kid she watched it over and
over and inspired her fashion inspired
her art i mean that's a look at you you
inspiring gaga
like i love lady gaga so much yeah
everything she does when she came out as
the man at the mtv awards i was like all
right we're done you've done it yeah
there's nothing you can't do she's like
our generation's david bowie i love her
i love her too uh well next for those of
you who love the great british bake off
anybody watch that show
well i mean it's the best um
if you've ever watched it and wondered i
wonder if they'll ever make a musical
out of this
well
you're not the only one because guess
what food and wine reports the great
british bake off the musical is debuting
this summer in england they're actually
doing it yeah a musical about the show
with 18 original songs it'll revolve
around eight amateur bakers and fans
will find out who would triumph as a
star baker and who will fall foul as a
soggy bottom um but turning into a
musical probably going to be expensive
but it costs a lot of dough oh
there it goes
so stupid so dumb but it got me thinking
like are there other shows that you love
that they should spin off into musicals
i don't know i i would see the
handmaid's tale on broadway oh you are
so dark that is the most depressing
musical of all time
i needed to be dramatico you know what i
mean i need ups and downs and love
stories like i want 90210 the musical
that's pretty good i love that and you
know that's gonna be musical next
[Music]
you